"THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT BIDEN SPINNING HIS
CHAOTIC EXIT FROM AFGHANISTAN IS
AN EXTRAORDINARY SUCCESS AS HIS
ADMINISTRATION REFUSES TO RULE
OUT WORKING WITH THE TALIBAN IN
THE FUTURE, PRIVATELY
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS SAY
THEY ARE HORRIFIED OVER
ABANDONING AMERICANS, ONE
TELLING POLITICO "I AM
ABSOLUTELY APPALLED AND
LITERALLY HORRIFIED WE LEFT
AMERICANS THERE.
IT WAS A HOSTAGE RESCUE OF
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS IN THE
GUISE OF A IN OPERATION.
DOING HIS BEST TO PAINT A ROSY
PICTURE OF.
>> IT'S EASY TO SECOND-GUESS BUT
LET'S JUST BE CLEAR, AMERICA WAS
IN THIS WAR FOR 20 YEARS AND I
THINK ANY EFFORT TO UNWIND AND
ANY EFFORT TO BRING OUR TROOPS
OUT, ANY EFFORT TO END OUR
MILITARY STANDS IN AFGHANISTAN
WAS GOING TO BE FILLED WITH
HEARTBREAKING SCENES AND
DIFFICULTIES, I THINK THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION MANAGED THAT AS
WELL AS IT COULD BE MANAGED
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES WE WERE
FORCED INTO.
>> Greg: THE TALIBAN SHOWED
OFF DUCT AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF U.S. MILITARY EQUIPMENT AND
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS NOT
RULING OUT WORKING WITH THE
TERRORIST IN THE FUTURE.
>> WHAT IS THE TALIBAN, ARE THEY
ARE OUR FRIEND AMI, ARE THEY ARE
ADVERSARY?
ARE THEY OUR ENEMY?
WHAT ARE THEY?
BECO IT'S HARD TO PUT A LABEL ON
IT.
>> AS FAR AS OUR DEALINGS WITH
THEM IN THE PAST YEAR OR SO, IN
WAR YOU DO WHAT YOU MUST.
TO REDUCE FORCE, NOT NECESSARILY
WHAT YOU WANT TO DO.
IT'S POSSIBLE.
>> Greg: THAT WAS UPBEAT.
ALL RIGHT, EVIL SHANNON,
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
OUT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN CALLS IT AN
EXTRAORDINARY SUCCESS.
YOU CAN ONLY APPLY THAT PHRASE
IF YOU APPLY IT TO A VERY NARROW
SPACE, LIKE WE GOT THE PLANE IN
THE AIR, THAT'S IT.
IF YOU INCORPORATE THE
HORRIFYING PROCESS AND THE LOSS
OF LIFE HOW CAN YOU SAY THAT?
>> Shannon: ALSO CLASSIFYING
IT AS AN EXTRAORDINARY SUCCESS
ARE CHINA, RUSSIA, IRAN, WE ARE
TO BE VERY COGNIZANT OF HOW THIS
PLAYS IN THE WORLD STAGE BECAUSE
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE CHEERING AND SAYING THIS IS
THE DEFEAT OF THE U.S. BUT WHEN
YOU HEAR THEM SAY WE DID THE
BEST THAT WE COULD IN THE
SITUATION WE HAD, I LOOK TO THIS
LETTER THAT CAME OUT A COUPLE
DAYS AGO, WAS A YOU CAN TELL ME
THAT THEY THOUGHT THIS WAS THE
BEST PLAN EVER, IF THEY DIDN'T
FULLY PUSH BACK AGAINST HIS
PRESIDENT AND SAY IT WAS A
TERRIBLE IDEA, THEY SHOULD
RESIGN, PEOPLE NEED SOME KIND OF
ACCOUNTABILITY BECAUSE TO SAY
THAT AND GO BACK TO THE PIT OF,
WE ALMOST EVERYBODY AGREES ON
THAT, IT'S ABOUT HOW WE LEFT AND
IF OUR MILITARY LEADERS GAVE
THIS PRESIDENT'S ADVICE THEN.
>> Greg: CONTINUING WITH THE
BAIT AND SWITCH, NOBODY IS
DEBATING THE DECISION TO LEAD
TO, LEAVE.
ONE THING WE DON'T TALK ABOUT AS
MUCH ANYMORE OTHER ALLIES, WE
UNDERSTAND THAT AMERICANS ARE
STILL THERE BUT WHAT ABOUT OUR
ALLIES?
THEY WERE THERE TO HELP US.
>> Will: WE LEFT SO MUCH
BEHIND, IT'S INTERESTING THAT
THEY QUALIFY IT BY A SUCCESS,
IGNORING THE 2,300, WHATEVER
NUMBER IT MAY BE, YOU KNOW WHAT,
YOU ARE 90% CANCER FREE.
THAT'S NOT AN ENCOURAGING
STATEMENT, THE PEOPLE WITH THE
SAME MIND-SET THAT SAID HERE'S A
MOSTLY PEACEFUL RIOT, THEY HAVE
A WAY OF CREATING THE SILVER
LINING SO I WOULD SUGGEST YOU
IGNORE THEM.
THE ANONYMOUS VOICES AND THEIR
ADMINISTRATION, LISTEN TO THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
THROWING THEM UNDER THE BUS, OUR
STANDARD IS LEAVE NO MAN BEHIND,
DON'T ACT LIKE THIS IS A
CATASTROPHE YOU ACTUALLY STEPPED
INTO ON THE SIDEWALK, YOU
CREATED THIS CATASTROPHE AND IT
IS YOUR BURDEN AND OBLIGATION TO
ENSURE THAT NO AMERICAN IS LEFT
BEHIND.
NO SPINNING, NO LYING, NO
CREATING A REALITY OTHER THAT.
>> YOU ACTIVELY SEEKING OUT
ANONYMOUS SOURCES, THERE WILL BE
HUNDREDS RIGHT NOW.
YOU HAVE A SERIOUS ISSUE WITH
THEIR PAST INTERPRETER, HAS
THERE BEEN ANY NEWS?
>> THERE IS, HE WAS 18 YEARS OLD
WHEN WE MET HIM.
HE BEGGED US TO GO WITH HIM.
TAKE US, TAKEN WITH US, HE
STAYED WITH US THE ENTIRE TIME,
12 ASSIGNMENTS IN AFGHANISTAN,
WONDERFUL GUY AND WE WERE SO
WORRIED ABOUT GETTING THEM OUT
BUT FOX NEWS DID AN AD ADMIRABLE
JOB ON THIS, WE GOT VIRTUALLY
ALL OF OUR PEOPLE OUT AND MANY
OF THE OTHER NETWORKS DID THE
SAME.
BECAUSE IT'S NEWS WHEN THINGS GO
BADLY, THE FACT THAT THIS WENT
RIGHT AND WE GOT THIS DEAR
FRIEND OUT AND HOPEFULLY, MY
FAMILY AND I WILL SPONSOR HIM
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES, YOU
KNOW --
>> Greg: THEY SHOULD MOVE IN
WITH YOU.
>> Geraldo: I HAVE SAID THAT I
WILL SPONSOR THEM.
>> Greg: I SEE A REALITY SHOW
GETS ME TO ONE POINT I WANT TO
MAKE IS THAT JFK, VICTORY HAS A
HUNDRED FATHERS, DEFEAT IS AN
ORPHAN.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SAY, LASER FOCUS
ON THE THING WE DID RIGHT,
GETTING 120,000 PEOPLE OUT AND
THEY DID ONE OF THE MOST
MAGNIFICENT AIRLIFT'S IN HISTORY
OF HUMAN RIGHTS.
WHAT WENT BADLY HOWEVER,
STICKING OUR CLAWS, WATCHING THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SAVAGE AND OUR
ENEMIES, CAN BE VERY, VERY
DIFFICULT FOR US TO BEAR.
BUT IT IS OUR NEW REALITY.
>> Greg: THIS ADMINISTRATION
KEEPS SAYING WE HAVE THIS
ENORMOUS LEVERAGE, BUT IT FEELS
LIKE WE ARE BASICALLY TELLING
THEM TO EXTORT US, WE ARE
ACTUALLY BEING OUR OWN
EXTORTIONISTS, FEEL FREE TO
HAMPER THE WITHDRAWAL UNTIL WE
GIVE YOU MONEY IS KIND OF WHAT
WE ARE SAYING, GO AHEAD, WE ARE
GOING TO GIVE YOU MONEY IF YOU
ENABLE US TO GET THESE PEOPLE
OUT.
BEFORE WE HAVE TREASURE BUT THEY
HAVE BLOOD.
WE FOUND OUT THE MAJORITY OF THE
INTERPRETERS, OTHER U.S. VISA
APPLICANTS WERE LEFT BEHIND IN
AFGHANISTAN,
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" REPORTING
TODAY, A MAJORITY AND WE FOUND
OUT THAT AT LEAST 500
JOURNALISTS FROM RADIO FREE
EUROPE AND RADIO LIBERTY AMONG
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES, 500
JOURNALISTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
WERE ALSO LEFT BEHIND.
IT WAS TOO MUCH TO EXPECT
PRESIDENT EMPATHY AND TODAY WE
GOT COMMANDER IN COWARDICE,
BIDEN AND COMPANY AND ALL OF
THESE DEMOCRATS HAVE DISPLAYED A
REAL TOTAL LACK OF RESPECT AND
REGARD FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE SAME RED NECKS AND FLY OVER
FOLKS BUT DISHING OUT WASHINGTON
BIO WASTE, LOOKING AT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND TELLING
DEMONSTRABLE LIES OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN AND ANYBODY WHO
HAS THE CAPABILITY OF HEARING
AND SEEING KNOWS THAT THEY ARE
BEING LIED TO AND YESTERDAY,
KIND OF GONE BETTER AND I THINK
ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
GENERAL MILLEY ONLY TOOK THREE
QUESTIONS TODAY IS BECAUSE THEY
ARE TRYING TO AVOID BEING PUT IN
A SITUATION WHERE THEY HAVE TO
EITHER LIVE FOR THE PRESIDENT OR
TELL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THE
TRUTH AND THE MOST DANGEROUS
THING TO ME IS JOE BIDEN IS
CLEARLY ACTING LIKE A ONE-TERM
PRESIDENT.
HE DOESN'T GIVE IT A DAMN AND IT
IS SCORCHED AMERICA, SCORCH
AFGHANISTAN, SCORCHED FEATURE
FUTURE BECAUSE HE WON'T BE
AROUND WHEN THE NEXT TERROR
ATTACK ARRIVES ON OUR SHOULDERS.
>> Greg: WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
SECOND-GUESSING MORE, WE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN FIRST GUESSING, IF
MORE PEOPLE WERE ENGAGED,
INCLUDING MYSELF AND THAT, THE
ABSENCE OF SECOND-GUESSING LED
TO THIS.
>> Dagen: I TO THINK IT WON'T
BE JOURNALISTS GOING TO
INSIDERS.
THEY WILL BE KEPT IN, WHEN ONE
COCKROACH COMES OUT, THAT'S WHEN
THEY'LL SHOW UP.
THE TWO YOU ARE REFERRING TO THE
WAR ITSELF, 20 YEARS OF LIES AND
HOW OFTEN DID WE HEAR ABOUT
FRIENDLY FIRE CASUALTIES AND THE
UGLY SIDE